faccio questa premessa io sto giocando a
questa cosa con il signor gatto che
saluto ogni giorno del giorno eccolo non
so cosa sto per giocare perché il signor
gatto ce lo deve spiegare
e un gioco semi horror o giudicare dai
facinorosi di sfondo però non capisco
cosa stiamo facendo sia mi dica noi
siamo stati ingaggiati anzi stiamo per
essere ingaggiati per andare alla
ricerca di un mostro che sta infestando
delle zone e noi saremo quelle persone
che dovranno liberarsene
bene gli inviti eccomi qua però io sono
livello meno 0
ma allora se ne frega allora va da
allora me piace enzo robin
beh sono scelgo quello però è il costo
dei soldi
esatto tu hai dei soldi che devi pagare
per comprare del personaggio perché una
volta morto è morto
che bello mi piace un sacco a una
domanda paura dei ragni e per caso
signor gatto prima di farmi queste
domande non può fare prima di comprare
il gioco invece direbbero no vero
sembrava cominciamo c'è ma gara chi
carica prima ci sono ancora qua salve ma
che bello
l'ho cercato e conduca ma anche lui
nella foresta delle meraviglie è bene
valutare prima di tutto stia attento
alle armi perché le munizioni sono
veramente poche mi spieghi come si fa le
cose essere il premier l'ha e si viva in
questo mondo ascetico leve delle lucine
blue sea lucine blu sono doveva doveva
fecondo vicina e vado verso la lunga
rete come nei film americani
e allora andiamo verso la luce la luce
ma lei la vede ma posso farlo quante
volte voglio questa quante volte vuole
porca vacca che kakà c'è un tizio ma lo
devo uscire immagino lo ha fatto lei lo
so penso molto bene tantissimi ma io non
sono proprio bravo in questo gioco c'è
una persona grossa lì lei e lei è
veramente fiducioso
la seguono dei manigoldi simili gli
sparo io in testa però non è ma ok
signori io non ho capito una cosa
ragazzi però è a no no no no no no no
non si fa perché no
ma l'altra gente dove dove godersi
questo manuello ma dove dove sono i
cattivi gli mostri da uccidere
allora noi dobbiamo scovare gli indizi
prima doveva aprendo le cose qua che ne
so io faccia qualcosa o scena lanterna
si allarga però è detto che pericolosa
quella lapo lanciare avessi quello
grosso signor gatto le varie per favore
salga su questo pezzo salendo non sale
ok
mamma mia che kakà e sale anche lui però
sa perché non pensavo non pensavo avevo
previsto che salisse noi invece siamo
presto venga qui venga michela salvo io
è troppo grosso signor gatto non va giù
è andato non è vero si è fatto io
bravo che così non vedo non so non c'è
l'entrata è morto lei no adesso si
cacciava h c'è gente strana adesso cos'è
quella roba lì
noi dobbiamo entrare dentro quella casa
notizia non lo vede e lo vedo però noi
dobbiamo andare lì e sbagliamo
vedo che mi curo intanto è morto
bravissimo sono forte lei lo vede il
buco per terra
lo prendo allora mi faccia delle fasi
listi che con le mani ho fatto ha fatto
benissimo avevo aperto era che la nuova
si è chiusa ah si certo dobbiamo
procedere verso l'obiettivo allora non è
qui andiamo oltre
perché una ragazza che una star e
randomico assolutamente sì molto bene o
capitoli che vuole la pappa pronta fa e
non ho chiesto un rogo bello era
possibile però bello mi piace questa
cosa c'è da cagarsi sotto facilmente pre
bello mi piace veramente tanto
per ora senza lei visto che sono suo
ospite non farmi camminare in mezzo alle
pozzanghere
adesso che pretese stiamo andando ad
ammazzare un porco sia effettivamente
non è che fino ad ora avevamo il tappeto
rosso steso per terra
poi c'è una porta per trento da sentito
mamma mia che brutte persone ma che non
aprono porte però se meglio ma lei mi
parla oggi di questo gioco quando
potevamo giocarci eoni fa per sempre ad
esempio ho sentito rumori bruttissimi
silenzio per l'amore del cea aia dello
spara che chi abbia sparato che male a
iano stia attento così uno dentro avere
dietro di noi faccia male sicuri che
sicuri come mi sicura come state le
paure una siringa con la siringa una
sincera siringa biglietto eh no non si
inietta così aspetti che tasto destro
anche male aia da 900 una molotov
bastardi orca vacca via via via signor
gato via venga qua noi dobbiamo uccidere
il mostro prima di loro oppure lo
facciamo uccidere a loro e noi lo
citiamo loro chiaro quello che faranno
loro
immagino sento però dei lamenti il
macellaio ok ma dove non glielo voglio
spoilerare troppo se lo vedremo perché
non è neanche detto se questi arriva
prima
dov'è il macellaio signor gatto venga
non so non lo vedo allora io credo che
sia qui sotto oppure qui dietro
no non è più il target found guardi io
credo che mi sa che l'ho trovato non
sono sicuro che sia questo ma
probabilmente questo io credo proprio
che sia quelle mi sa che quello signor
gatto è veramente grosso ma fortissimo
grosso gli spari maledizione che male
vada via da lì che fa male fa mallorca
miseria ha ucciso
mi sa che hai e large mores venga qua
per me mamma mia per questo sale ovunque
sono la pala lanci lanci hanno mai lei
che va a fuoco nella lanterna
eccolo qua a metà mendes corre corre
attenzione che corre venga qua spari
farini bifa blog di blogging lo stanno
le società di allora lo star milos tagli
che male dopo non mi cadono mica da così
bannaggio mannaggia proprio qui dove la
cas carmi avere tutto a posto
ok vediamo quasi troviamo magari qualche
cura intorno ma non mi ha colpito è
andata è andata giù la maschera e allora
è morto praticamente è no non è proprio
morto e andato di là
adesso viene qua è morto romani morto se
adesso lo dobbiamo bandire noi dobbiamo
aspettare la fine di quella percentuale
lì mentre tutto il server sa che siamo
qui l'abbiamo ucciso molto bene
aspettiamo eccone uno maledizione e
quanto sono forti non li vedo e dove
sono io praticamente e ma avranno fatto
il giro sono mica scemi aspetti che devo
provare a farlo crowley ha mancato l'ho
colpito però sono morto non si facesse
qualcuno mi ha sputato addosso né morto
va bene però e mi è piaciuto
riproviamoci e quel giorno e giorno
danno perché lei e nero ma cosa succede
qua lei mi è un razzista
no non sono razzisti l'allegria della
mattina prego entry lei aspetti che
coach e della cura lì però non le serve
erano il museo per me è male la porta ma
che gestivo porca vacca non è stata
l'accoglienza più bella del mondo essere
ti aspetti che faccio faccio il mare di
mano go for e va di lei che quel casino
fermo e vabbè non c'era niente che
ragiona bisogno di una manetta le mie
entra
ma lei è scemo io ti guardo ma non
c'entro anch'io vada che veloci contro
chiuso si chiude si chiude faccia uscire
mi faccio uscire ma che schifo erode
scavalco mai no signor gato io dei
problemi
il ragazzo faccia velo signor gatto
signor gatto signor gatto spari il
signor gatto bari io sono lo presa dai
anche male che male ma di sopra che
schifo signor gatto che schifo che mi fa
è stato lei signor gatto fa veramente
vomitare spariva spy paribas veramente
secolo prima io l'ho preso però lui era
ce l'avevo in faccia in questo istante
misto contenendo perché siamo in un dual
commentari sono a quest'ora sarei
veramente io
vabbè metto della musica allegra la
ringrazio per strada lo faccia anche
quando vedo mazzarani
non vedo niente ecco gli spari fari che
schifo quanto è veloce questa roba così
una bella giornata avevo detto che era
del 50 per cento
mamma mia è quasi morto lo vedo più
eccolo qui bravo è andato ora cavalca
cosa non è morta elisa ares adesso è
morto ci mette un pochino
ecco qui spider man issing ok inter 102
per cento aspettiamo mettiamo po di
musica che stanno facendo aspettare ma
loro sanno dove siamo gli impegni
lontano adesso no non credo almeno spari
spagna
mamma mia è stato bellissimo corra ma io
vado lento non so come mai
enzo citando a c'è un cavallo va bene il
cavallo lo accetto ok non vedo nessuno
in vista non vedo nessun in vista mela
segno cercato abbiamo vinto mamma mia mi
vissuto per morire un altro giorno hai
visto va bene che bello è stato è stato
un gioco simpatico
va bene ragazzi io spero che video vi
sia piaciuto ringrazio il signor gatto
per avermi fatto reso partecipe anziché
questa opera videoludica è molto bello
molto bello tranne per il ragno proprio
essere veramente bello mi dispiace che
sia giocato non tantissimo quanto vero
però secondo me ha un gran potenziale
speriamo spacchi gli ho avuto lì
[Musica]